bonjour à tous il ya de ça quelques
jours j'étais à berlin à l'ifa et j'ai
pu essayer plein de nouveaux produits
voir plein de nouvelles choses et je
vous en parle sur ma chaîne mais j'ai pu
tester un production des depuis très
très longtemps
c'est la nouvelle console de microsoft
la xbox one x j'ai pu jouer sur un mode
100% 4k une télé 4k une console 4k est
un jeu optimisé pour les quatre cas à
savoir forza motosport set j'ai pu
uniquement joue à ce jeu avec sua qui
était en version de démo et de tests sur
le stand de microsoft mais en tout cas
que vous assurer que c'est pas été déçu
la console est tenu ses promesses et le
jeu franchement est super sympa si vous
ne connaissez pas je m'appelle monsieur
grumes à chaîne parle de votre vie
numérique parle de vote stratégie que tu
parles de tous les produits d' influence
ce soit des smartphones tout ce sont
même des consoles que ce soit des objets
connectés
on parle de tout ça pour vous aider à
progresser dans votre vie numérique vous
invite à vous abonner à la chaîne et
activer la cloche en manquer aucune
publication
vous avez déjà parlé à plusieurs
reprises tout d'abord du projet scorpion
ou alors on connaissait pas encore le
nom de la xbox onyx et puis ensuite la
xbox nixon a été présentée par microsoft
une console que j'avais vraiment hâte de
tester et il vous assure je n'ai pas été
déçue la vision fasse un écran 4 cas une
console optimisés jeux optimisés
c'est bluffant les lumières sont
vraiment sympas les détails sont d'une
fluidité extraordinaire j'ai essayé la
nissan gt x sur un mode course bien
évidemment cette jeu de course et ça a
été juste top
au début on part il fait super beau et
puis au fur et à mesure qu'on avance
dans la course s'il se met à pleuvoir
est-ce que vous assurer qu'à voir les
gouttes d'eau qui arrive sur l'écran qui
ruisselle c'est vraiment bluffant parce
que c'est vraiment faim on a vraiment
l'impression de d'avoir des gouttes sur
l'écran il ya une vraie netteté et
brillance c'est même presque plus beau
que la réalité c'est ça qui est
extrêmement bluffant alors le jeu je
sais pas vous en parler en long en large
et en travers parce que je l'essayé
peine pendant cinq minutes pour sa moto
sport 7 est très sympa en prison ça se
conduit bien l'enquêté sur un mode
vraiment pour les mec qui a envie de se
prendre la tête
un mode de vraiment facile à piloter
mais bien évidemment c'est un jeu qui
peut être beaucoup plus complexe on peut
faire énormément de choses avec mes déjà
ne serait ce que sur une prise en main
rapide il est vraiment extrêmement
agréable très sympa si vous avez
l'occasion si un jeu que je vous
conseille de tester alors leur remontée
sur le salon je n'avais pas le droit de
filmer uniquement que l'écran il fallait
forcément qui est un petit peu de recul
pour qu'on voie l'environnement à noter
quand même que vous jouez en nuage des à
60 images seconde et c'est ça vraiment
qu'il va conférer beaucoup de fluidité
au jeu et qui va donner vraiment du
réalisme on voit très bien qu'avec ce
jeu la puissance de la console est
vraiment exploiter je pense qu'on peut
encore aller plus loin à voir sur
d'autres jeux du genre qui sont
peut-être plus gourmands le seul point
négatif que j'ai pu relever c'était le
temps de chargement du jeu
je les trouvais quand même relativement
longue je leur ai demandé pourquoi
edmond d'hibarette tous non parce que
c'est un prototype mais sur la version
officielle de la console ça ira beaucoup
plus vite
j'avais pas le droit de filmer la
console on m'a dit que c'était un
prototype c'est un petit peu décevant
parce que j'aurais bien aimé pouvoir
vous la montrer c'est comme un petit peu
compliqué que sur une console de cette
génération avec la puissance et toutes
les capacités de calcul qu'elle a dans
le ventre qu'elle ne cherche pas les
jeunes s'est rapidement voilà ça c'est
un peu le point négatif faudra voir
lorsque la version officielle de la
console sera sorti six petits points n'a
été corrigé
à priori oui je pense n'y a pas à
s'inquiéter alors comme je le disais
c'est compliqué se faire une idée
globale sur cette console en juste cinq
minutes de test surtout sur un seul jeu
mais en tout cas par rapport à ce que
j'ai pu lire par rapport à ce qui a été
annoncé par microsoft est ce que j'ai pu
lire à droite à gauche ça tient ses
promesses
mais exactement dans ce que j'ai pu lire
sur différents tests sur le web ou voir
sur youtube la console est sympa si vous
êtes un fan de microsoft si vous aimez
les jeux de voiture si vous avez un
écran 4 cas vous vous ferez plaisir
parce que on est en immersion complète
avec un jeu qui est extrêmement flux des
graphismes très réaliste et on se fait
plaisir
dites moi ce que vous en pensez en
commentaire est ce que vous envisagez
d'acheter cette console j'ai déjà lu les
commentaires sur mes précédentes vidéos
il est effectivement deux écoles il ya
vraiment des personnes qui sont vraiment
fans de saunier de la playstation et qui
attendent la playstation 5 pour venir
rivaliser avec cette xbox one x il ya
aussi énormément personnes qui sont fans
de microsoft et qui adore la xbox la
rétrocompatibilité avec les gens par
ailleurs c'est vrai que c'est quelque
chose de super sympa même si les jeux
sont plus beau graphiquement on pourra
pas avoir un à quatre cas super optimisé
pour vraiment profiter de la 4k et la
puissance de cette mort il faudra des
jeux dernière génération super autorisé
comme celui-là comme assassin's creed et
comme d'autres à venir
dites moi ce que vous en pensez en
commentaire est ce qu'elle vous
intéresse oui non qu'est ce que vous en
pensez vous marquez tout ça on en parle
ensemble si vous avez des questions vous
pouvez contacter @ monsieur dreux avec
le hashtag ask monsieur grog sur twitter
vous invite à vous abonner à ma chaise
et activer la cloche pour ne manquer
aucune publication plus donne rendez
vous très très très bientôt pour une
prochaine vidéo et d'ici là portez vous
bien
ciao
[Musique]